what's up guys
lunch money time while while she's
trying to get rich russell's just trying
to get her lunch money right
bang bang what's up oh not much
you look like you're in prison with your
prisoner outfit not at all what a
prisoner outfit looks like or maybe it's
like a sailor outfit
maybe okay don't forget lunch money is
now sponsored by block five block five
okay has three products you can buy and
sell crypto you can deposit crypto and
earn
a us dollar loan rights get a us dollar
loan can't really earn it but you can
get a us dollar loan against your crypto
collateral and you can earn
uh that's where the earned part goes
earn 8.6 apy in an interest bearing
account no-brainer go and check out
block fight i'm an investor i sit on the
board i'm a user
basically it's my favorite company in
crypto go check them out
blocify.com 8.6
apy you ain't gonna get that at your
granddaddy's checking account for safety
gotta get rid of that
brown sugar thing right here okay
what's going on in uh the economist
stephen roach's world
who is stephen roach and he's an
economist okay
economist stephen roach warns i'm no
genius but i got that one
warns that next year will be brutal for
the dollar
not only does he see growing odds of a
double dip recession
is that like the fat cat bounce um it's
called a dead cat bounce
the yale university senior fellow
believes his seemingly crazy idea that
the dollar would crash
wouldn't be so crazy anymore
this makes no sense what he's saying
wait why because
in a recession the dollar gets stronger
it doesn't crash
right now but it's a double dip
recession i think it's a recession then
it goes
no we had a recession the feds stepped
in they
injected a bunch of liquidity into the
market so think think of it like a
see-saw right for those of you at home
where am i
think of it like a see-saw as the dollar
strengthens
asset prices go down right because it's
a fraction
so let's say a stock is one share
right is what you're buying and it's
denominated in dollars and so
if it takes more dollars to buy that
share that means that the dollar is
weakening right it you need more of them
to buy it
but if it takes less dollars to buy that
share
than the dollar strengthening he
elaborates lacking and saving and
wanting to grow we run these current
account deficits to borrow
plus saving surplus
and that always pushes the currencies
lower
the dollar is not immune to that
time-honored adjustment i
do not know what i just said so the way
to think about this is
in a recession there's usually a
liquidity so even just look in the last
couple of days
you probably haven't been paying
attention to this but stocks have sold
off
so stocks are down they're down about
nine percent almost 10 percent right
and when they're selling off if you look
over the last four days the dollar has
actually
increased in strength more in the last
four days than it has at almost any
period in this recession
so again it's that seesaw so when prices
go down dollar strengthens when
the prices go up the dollar weakens so
what he's basically saying is
prices are going to go down and the
dollar is going to crash that's not how
it works
and so unless i'm missing something that
he's saying here uh it doesn't make a
lot of sense
what i do believe is possible is that
asset prices can continue to pump
through federal reserve and other
central bank manipulation
and the dollar can crash so there's a
possibility that the dollar crashes is
just
going to be in a different scenario than
what he's doing are you saying mr roach
doesn't know what he's talking about
i'm saying that economists are uh very
academic
and uh the real world is sometimes not
in line with their views
do you remember last time where it was
like 50 of economists say this and i was
like okay but what did
the other 50 say
okay jp morgan chase is close to paying
almost
one billion dollars to resolve
government investigation into the
alleged manipulation of metal and
treasury's
markets that's a billion dollar fine
so yeah this would a penalty of that
size would be a record for spoofing
which is when sophisticated traders
flood markets with orders that they have
no intention
of actually executing the practice was
banned after the 2008 financial crisis
a lot of things were banned after the
2000s you know what spoofing is
yeah what it's like when all these
traders put the trades up but they don't
have any intention of trading them so
they just flood the market and it looks
like there's a lot of
um um what is it called not demand but
surplus
no demand so basically what they do is a
very over generalized manner is let's
say something's trading at ten dollars
they'll put in buy orders at a certain
price
right or sell orders or whatever and
what they're trying to do is if everyone
sees oh wait there's a ton of people who
want to buy this at 12
and it's sitting at 10 naturally the
price will go like start moving up
that doesn't sound right and then
basically when it gets higher then they
just pull the order
and so it never actually executes can't
believe you can just pull the order
well think about it if you're saying hey
i want to buy this at twelve dollars
it's at ten dollars
right or better would be uh i wanna buy
it at nine dollars it said it currently
at ten as it's dropping
right and then it gets down to nine
dollars i never don't wanna buy it
anymore
right yeah i mean look all this stuff
goes on
everywhere it's a cat and mouse game
between the banks and law enforcement
the fact that it's a billion dollar five
million dollars
that's big but it's not really that big
right
does it say what uh jp morgan's revenue
no but i can look at it but
it was part of a 14 count criminal uh
jp morgan's always in something well
there's a big bank right
so so revenue is 115.6
billion last year so literally it's less
than
one percent of their revenue last year
think about it that way
less than one percent of their revenue
yeah so literally they made 115 billion
in revenue
and they had to pay a billion dollar
fine so it's like the better question is
how much money did they make off of the
metals desk
right let's say that they made three
billion dollars came off their metals
desk
and it's only a billion dollar fine it
actually is profitable to do this
even with the fine and so what a lot of
banks do is
is they just uh budget in money
to pay fines and when they get in
trouble and stuff it's just part of the
business model
i don't like it all right what's next
all right mark cuban mr mark so there's
13 million americans unemployed and
thousands of businesses permanently
closed across the us but congress is in
an impasse
and it looks unlikely that a deal on
another stimulus package will happen
anytime soon
so mark cuban said
uh there are two economies one oh sorry
or two sets of realities right now one
for those
who are able to stay afloat and one for
those who are unable to
those without help are struggling badly
he says we need to get them
help so k-shaped recovery
everyone was talking about is it going
to be an l
so drop and then it goes sideways is it
going to be a v
is it going to drop and come back right
away uh and so
now there's talk of something called a
k-shaped recovery right if you think of
just a
letter k some people prosper other
people at home yep and i wrote this
morning and
published it out uh publicly that uh
there's all this data now coming out
simple things like um let's take math
progress
in students so they have a way of
measuring basically how uh how much
progress are students making in these
online uh math stuff
and uh if you look at the total number
it's up four and a half percent since
this year
like like classes right like basically
our students uh progressing in math
so it's up 4.5 since the beginning of
the year as a total for the national
average
sounds pretty good when you break it out
by high income and low income
the high income students are up over 50
right than they were in january the low
income students are down almost 30
so literally the high income is way up
in the air low it comes down i wrote a
whole article about financial literacy
around this
but going that was just math then if you
look at employment
basically if you have a high paying job
you
we're almost at full employment to where
we were not full employment but we were
at employment where we were in january
so essentially for high income workers
the recession's over
like they're back to work everything's
great if you're a low income worker
it's more than 20 down and so therefore
again there's
these two americas that are playing out
the rich are getting richer because
asset prices are going up
and also they're back to employment
levels that they were before
consumer spending's back all that kind
of stuff but
if you are not rich then you end up
actually having high levels of
unemployment
i think 80 percent of the job loss right
now is coming from
low income type roles so we're talking
we're talking like seasonal jobs well
it's just
it's service hospitality like some of
the other data points i remember
are uh if you look at small businesses
across america
20 of them are not open right now
compared to january uh some of that's
permanent closure some of that still
they're just closed
you keep yawning sorry and if you break
out that 20
uh it's like 50 give or take
is leisure and hospitality right and
then if you look at things like
restaurants and stuff like that maybe
that's like
30 or 25 or whatever but there's certain
industries that are getting hammered
and then the saddest part of the entire
thing in my opinion
is if you actually look at consumer
spending
total it's down uh i think it was down
like four percent
right our economy was built well across
the united states
it's down four percent if you break it
out by high income and low income
rich people are spending 10 percent less
than they were in january
people who are not rich low income
interesting they're spending more
why because again it goes back to the
whole idea of like
everyone doesn't experience the same
level of inflation everyone doesn't have
the same needs
so things like um if you're low income
right
you've got to go buy food you've got to
buy transportation if you don't have a
job you actually have more time to go
do things and spend money on your costs
are actually going up in some cases
and that can be because literally the
goods that you buy are different than
the goods that somebody who's high
income buys
and therefore there's literally a gap so
if you think about a low income
uh family today they're more likely to
be unemployed
they're more likely to be spending more
on a percentage basis than high income
people
and also if they have children their
children are getting a
uh are their education's going down in
terms of progress rather than going i
think
i i do think that it's like inequality
starts early and it does start with
education as someone who's been in
schools where
uh very very
like lower income schools and then i
went
to something that was a little bit more
high income all public schools
it it just you can see the difference in
education
and uh in teaching and everything well
in fifth grade i think i was fifth grade
fourth or fifth grade i can't remember i
think it was fifth grade
uh i i went to public school all the way
through to fifth grade
and all the way to hold on and in fifth
grade uh
in the middle of the year my parents
took me out uh i maybe wasn't the best
behaving kid
but uh we can imagine i remember
literally like it was so it was such
like cognitive dissonance because i was
in a
public school one week and the next week
i was in this private school
uh yeah how was private school they
weren't [ __ ] they weren't screwing
around
i like i started saying things that i
would say in the public school and they
were just like we don't do that here and
i was like what do you mean you don't do
that here like
well what i
i literally remember i like in the
hallway i said it and like a kid went
and ran and told the teacher
and i was just like yeah i'm a whoop
your hat but even within public school
so i was in public school all the way
through high school
in college yeah and college but um like
you would notice the difference between
like on level classes
and then honors classes and ap classes
in in on level classes the teachers
really put a premium on
are you going to be on time are you
sitting are you quiet or whatever
and then my ap classes like literally i
could come in the middle of class they
wouldn't bat an eye because they knew
that i would get my work done i would
sit i would whatever but it's just like
that level of trust that you don't get
i don't know it's just i don't know um i
don't like it
the uh the school that i went to uh for
high school
was also uh real crazy
and um i didn't know that we had i knew
we had honors classes
but what's the other one called ap yeah
when i was in college somebody i asked
them if they had like
like a science class or something and
they were like nah i don't have to take
that i was like wait how did you not
have to take it
like i took it in high school i was like
damn you're a nerd like you must've been
really smart and they're like no you
could take an ap
class it counts as college credit i was
like oh my high school didn't have that
and a true story and they were like no
i'm pretty sure it had it i was like nah
i
literally never heard that before like
we didn't have that and so they're like
no you had it so i called a friend
like the smartest kid that i knew and i
was like yo man uh you ever heard of
these ap
classes and he was like yeah dude i was
in all of them you just weren't in them
and i was like oh well got it so i
wasn't in any honors
i wasn't in any ap classes i was just in
the normal stuff just chilling
we talked about this all the time if we
had met when we were in high school or
college like
first of all you would have been fawning
overnight oh yeah been like
wow look at that stud okay
all right well speaking of education
jeff bezos
is opening a tuition-free preschool for
underserved children called bezos
academy
um i like this idea so it actually looks
really good i looked through some of the
pictures but i don't know what the level
of education is
he he announced the details in an
instagram post on tuesday it's the first
location of a network of
tuition-free preschools serving children
in underserved communities
spearheaded by bezos's philanthropic arm
day one fund yeah but basically he's
going to use montessori type
education right it's inspired by
montessori yeah no-brainer
it says the new school the new school
will which will serve three to five
years year olds wow
that's a typo on cnn business come on
will be located in des moines washington
and it will open
on october 17th the selection process
are based on a wide range of data the
fund says which include
income levels participation and free and
reduced cost meal programs
and gaps in access to licensed child
care providers i love this
even though you know many of you may
have opinions about bezos i'm
all about opening schools there's a
there's a saying in bulgarian
those who those who open schools close
prisons
it's probably true all right what's next
okay hold on
what do you mean hold on we don't got
time to hold on hold on
the people are busy on business
california governor
wants all new cars sold in the state to
be zero emissions by 2035 he wants a lot
of things this guy
gavin newsom announced an executive
order
requiring that all new passenger cars
and trucks sold in the state
zero emission vehicles by 2035. is that
allowed for him to do an
executive order on something like this i
mean this is just
classic political it's like pr right
yeah it's just oh
2035. that's only 15 years from now
and it's going to be zero emission
anyways because that's what is
most economical for the car
manufacturers
yeah he he sounds a little bit like the
kid i wouldn't like in high school
okay um whatever that's fine final you
want to know a crazy stat about gavin
newson
no the governor of california his
ex-wife is now married to donald trump's
son
it's not a stat that's a fact whatever
stat fact whatever
and one ex-wife is now married is that
the same lady that was like crazy
i don't know well i don't know if it was
crazy i think you mean uh being
flamboyant
no no no no no during the republican
night yeah being flamboyant with their
arms
a flamboyant is one way to put it okay
um
2020s happiest states in america came
out
what what how how far down on the list
is new york not that far
no 17 17 but guess who the top three are
top three if i had to guess i'm gonna go
with somewhere
somewhere in uh the pacific northwest
maybe one what what is that like oregon
washington
somewhere up there uh another one i'm
gonna go with
is like uh the vermont new hampshire
somewhere up there uh and then i'm gonna
go
with uh maybe somewhere
in the like new mexico arizona denver
type area what are they i don't think
you've got any of them uh i'll give you
the top five
hawaii utah minnesota
new jersey and maryland okay i got you
what the hell is new jersey up there
what is new jersey germany new jersey uh
people they just convince themselves
they're happy oh my god
they live in the armpit of america based
on emotional kidding
my brother emotional and physical
well-being work environment community
and environment rank and that was just
the total score
overall what do you think are the most
miserable states
uh california
um most miserable states maybe like
north or south dakota think opioids oh
west virginia
kentucky well it's west virginia
arkansas oklahoma louisiana and kentucky
um i feel like west virginia just always
gets a bad rap man
hard life coal miner coal mining country
okay
all right what's next bang bang let's go
this day in
fun fact trivia on september 24th
in 1794 u.s president george washington
ordered a 15 000 man militia
to suppress an uprising of western
pennsylvania farmers
they were protesting an excise duty
placed on stills and spirits
distilled in the us so george washington
was out here suppressing protests
of course oh my god he like wrote the
constitution
we're just gonna leave that one alone
we're just gonna we're not
uh we're not gonna touch that guys
but why would he suppress freedom of
speech in alcohol
i feel like alcohol is in the
constitution dude have you ever heard of
something called prohibition
yes what is it i used to work at a
restaurant as a waitress that was called
the
oh okay you must have really paid
attention at work prohibition
term it's okay but prohibition was when
you couldn't drink
the the volstead do you know what a
volstead is
yeah of course what is it huh it's the
wolf said act
which is the national prohibition act
that was the restaurant i worked at if
you went to athens georgia between 20
guys these this day in history
nonsense is whatever but i got a joke
for you guys today this joke is all
time do you know how to kill a circus
clown
you go for the jugular
polina didn't let me say the three jokes
that i wanted to say she said they were
too inappropriate for this kids show
so i had to settle on that one all right
do you have any last words for the
people
um it's my brother's birthday joe
pompliano what up
happy birthday and be kind to your
friends i haven't reminded you
recently all right guys that's it see
you tomorrow bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange i personally
use the interest bearing account
there's not very many places where
you'll find up to 8.6
interest on a deposit in an interest
bearing account go do your own research
there's risk associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfy
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends